well at Chop Shop operating at a North
Las Vegas Home Police telling us two men
were arrested after someone reported
suspicious activities neighbors telling
us several cars were constantly coming
into a home on Putnam Avenue which is
near Civic Center and Kerry when
officers arrived one neighbor said he
was surprised to learn about the crime
happening outside his home
it's crazy I think their dad lives there
and I don't think he knew what was going
on Ricardo Herrera is still shaken up
about what happened outside his North
Las Vegas home after a series of random
cars began to show up next door they're
bringing a lot of cars now it's now two
or three at the same time and it's
different people coming in every time
according to North Las Vegas Police on
Friday morning someone reported Two Men
and some suspicious activity outside
this home on Putnam Avenue
sharing this video with 8 news now as
law enforcement was getting ready to
approach the neighborhood about an hour
later they told us we had to evacuate
because they were gonna bring in the
SWAT team to break the door down Herrera
and his mom left their home which is
attached to the suspect's home one
neighbor sharing this image which shows
a sniper on the roof of a nearby Home
officers arrested 29-year-old Saul
Sanchez and 31 year old Michael vizcarra
also wearing an ankle monitor on Monday
several tools were laying on the
property pescara and Sanchez were both
booked on four counts of stolen vehicle
five counts of possession of a stolen
vehicle and one count of operating a
Chop Shop literally right next door and
they were doing these things and they
just you know didn't assume the words
try to assume the best of people at
least I do
well North Las Vegas Police told us a
concerned neighbor was a person that
reported the tip now police would not
say how long the Chop Shop was operating
but we can tell you that both men are
expected in court tomorrow